welcome to Hannity a big weekend
celebration for the radical socialist
far-left Democrats in this country there
she is
congresswoman Alexandria Acacio Cortes
suggesting that this great country of
ours is garbage that capitalism is
irredeemable Ronald Reagan and FDR's New
Deal was racist
we have fake news chief CNN president
Jeff Zucker trashing FoxNews and
everyone who works here I have a
response for him tonight
also known liar Adam well shifty
cowardly Schiff he sent his supporters
out a letter a desperate plea for help
begging for money using my name trying
to raise money on my name because we
dared to call him out we will call him
out again tonight and stay tuned because
we'll cover this very important Hannity
watch on the sad state of this
Democratic Party it's also a dangerous
state we start with the Speaker of the
House in name only Nancy Pelosi in an
interview with The Washington Post
Pelosi said impeaching President Trump
it's just not worth it because the
process is too divisive here's my
message tonight do not ever believe a
single word she says Pelosi now presides
over what is the most radical extreme
group of socialist Democrats that have
ever existed that includes socialist
members of Congress that we know want to
get rid of oil and gas the lifeblood of
our economy
all gasp powered cars cows and planes in
the next 10 years and tell everybody
it's free everything's free whether
you're willing or unwilling to work and
breaking tonight well the person that's
really leading the Democratic Party
Acacio Cortes she doesn't think Trump's
impeachment is off the table
I believe her more than Pelosi Pelosi's
utterly controlled by these new radicals
and she knows her power is in jeopardy
every day she will go with their every
whim and I have a message for those that
think you know Oh socialism is so cool
everything's free
well democratic well genius Alexandra
kostikova Cortez over the weekend she
took a plane you know we're not supposed
to have those in ten or twelve years
well the world's gonna end in 12 years
where she offered her expertise on a
variety
of issues at the South by Southwest
festival so liberal festival naturally
she found time to bash capitalism and
America in the process let's take a look
capitalism isn't to me is it's an
ideology of capital
it puts capital the most important thing
is the concentration of capital and it
means that we seek and prioritize profit
and the accumulation of money above all
else and we seek it at any human and
environmental cost that is what that
means and to me that ideology is not
sustainable and cannot be redeemed yeah
an irredeemable system that has lifted
more people out of poverty than any
other system in the history of mankind
on earth an economic system that has
drastically improved the quality of life
for hundreds and hundreds of millions of
Americans over time billions of others
trying to duplicate our system around
the world but Acacio Cortez he wants to
trade it in for a socialist system like
Venezuela North Korea Cuba the former
Soviet Union and that's not all Kazi of
cortez also went on to suggest that the
united states is pretty unbelievable is
we're basically a garbage country take a
look we've strayed so far away from what
has really made us powerful and just and
good and equitable and productive and so
I think all of these things sound
radical compared to where we are but
where we are is not a good thing and
this idea of like 10% better from
garbage it shouldn't be what we settle
for in reality the only things 10%
better than garbage in this country are
some of these ridiculous ideas and the
sad and scary part is these beliefs are
shared by what 20 20 presidential
candidates over a hundred Democrats now
and like any far-left extremist the
lawmakers views would not be complete
without everyone thinking everyone
pretty much as a racist in torreón
mark she called FDR's New Deal racist
even suggesting Ronald Reagan's a racist
take a look a perfect example of how
special interests and the powerful have
pitted white working-class Americans
against brown and black working-class
Americans in order to just screw over
all working-class Americans is is
reaganism in the 80s when you started
talking about welfare queens because
these one this one specific group of
people that you are already kind of
subconsciously primed to resent you give
them a different reason
that's not explicit racism but still
read it in a racist caricature let's
recap Acacio cortez the new radical
extreme socialist democrats enlightening
the crowd at the South by Southwest
festival by calling Reagan a racist FDR
a racist suggesting the United States is
based on a garbage system and she wants
you the American people to hand over the
keys to your private business as your
private property she wants the
government control of the means of
production literally she wants state
control of all healthcare how did that
Obamacare work out and all energy we're
gonna be no oil or gas in ten years good
luck and she wants to tell every
business how to operate oh boy and
according to her her government knows
best not you not we not the American
people not the people who risk reward
incentive and create goods and services
that make our lives easier and better
that people want need and desire she and
her colleagues know better which is a
pretty disturbing concept because she
actually had a business and we found out
tonight she owes nearly nineteen hundred
dollars in back taxes over her small
defunct business that she found that in
2012
remember socialism is all about do as I
say not as I do
and you're always generous with other
people's money we're all supposed to pay
taxes not them she's just in government
to reap the rewards
I'll have more on this coming up tonight
first I want to turn our focus to the
arm of the Democratic Party and that of
course is fake news all over the place
but in this particular case fake news
CNN now the network will soon be facing
a whopping 250 million dollar lawsuit
for it's willful smears slander besmirch
meant libel of Covington high school
student Nick Sandman I'm gonna make a
prediction CNN is going to lose a
fortune you know
attorney Lynwood he's been on this show
he will crush them their public
vilification of a young 16 year old high
school student who did nothing wrong
showed incredible grace under pressure
was nothing short of it it's just a
disgrace his life will never be the same
but their rush to judgment wasn't just
immediate went on for more than two days
and don't forget CNN singled out Sandman
why he was wearing a red make America
great again hat the new trigger for the
extreme left now recently CNN president
professional trumpeter
Otto presides over all of that lows lies
against the 16 year old he emerged from
his Glass House had the gall to call the
Fox News Channel a propaganda outlet
Jeff I have a message for you how about
a public apology from you and your
on-air talent if you want to call them
talent your networks
you're disgusting rush to judgment
you're smearing your slandering let's
just stay with a 16 year old kid and
your networks hatred of Trump which
caused this because that's all you cover
every second of every day and you also
said the employees work here my friends
and colleagues support a place that has
done tremendous damage to the country
look at the damage you did to that 16
year old would you like it if it was
your kid that from Zucker the head of
the network that literally hates Trump
so much they'll go after a 16 year old
and not ask a single question about
whether what they hear and see a snippet
is true
like the fake story let's go through
CNN's history about Trump
remember Trump and the prime minister
feeding the fish in the pond yeah they
got that wrong or CNN fake news story
about Trump and WikiLeaks
yeah wrong again or the fake news story
about Trump and Russia that forced three
CNN journalists to resign wrong or the
fake news story about sessions and
Russia that they were forced to walk
back wrong again or the fake news story
predicting that Comey would refute Trump
nope and Fox and fake news goes on and
on and on every day every hour of
conspiracy theory after conspiracy
theory all driven by an irrational rage
and hatred for president Trump do they
ever tell one success story record low
unemployment for African Americans
Hispanic Americans Asian Americans women
in the workplace millions out of poverty
off of food stamps every second hour of
every day every year for three years now
sadly this hatred it's only the tip of
the iceberg journalism is dead their
anti Trump obsessive coverage it's
impossible to watch which is probably
why so few Americans actually watch
alright we've got the video proof as
Warner wolf used to say let's go to the
videotape impeachment impeachment
impeached impeachment impeachment
impeachment impeachment impeachment
teachable teachable picture in Russia
investigation colluded Putin collusion
delt film actress stormy Daniels stormy
Daniels the stormy saga to stormy
Daniels affair adult film star stormy
Daniels
she's a polar is there a difference if
the president said whole-house do you
think these countries are poles Donald
Trump has turned the Oval Office into I
know the really sad part of what they
call is news we know it's not is that
many people sadly around the world don't
you see a bigger picture here they see
America through the lens of CNN
International and their coverage pretty
wide reaching as they were the first
cable news so-called news network on the
on the market they're giving the world a
very distorted perverted view of our
country every single day they never talk
about America's greatness America
success the president success just hate
Trump all day long that's what the world
sees through the CNN lens and of course
in addition to their obsessive coverage
we know that fake news CNN also utilizes
bias of omission again to malign the
president look at this study from News
Buster's CNN's Wolf Blitzer though
Situation Room frequently promoted the
congressional Democrats frivolous and
wrong investigations into the president
last week Blitzer found time to ask 86
on critical questions about the
investigation while asking only three
that challenge the never ending
inquiries in spite of all of the news we
had last week if Zucker really wants to
see propaganda just look at your own
Network because that's all you are
and while sucker and his fake news
minions are busy hating all things Trump
all the time they also continue to
provide 24/7 cover for the collusion
conspiracy theorist Adam Schiff and we
change gears Adam shifts sent out a
fundraising letter this weekend
literally his team team Adam they are
begging they're pleading for help all
because of this show and that we dared
to tell the truth and call out his
constant lying and leaking in a new
fundraiser ploy there's Adam well we
call him the cowardly Schiff because he
won't come on the program but he's
begging supporters to pitch in at least
five bucks please to send a message to
Hannity after he dedicated 40 minutes of
his show covering the cowardly shift and
add to the quote trust us Adam isn't
about to back down because he's Sean
Hannity best part of all this is Howard
Lee shift we've offered them the full
hour
even after liberal Bill Maher told them
to do it congressman I'll give you three
hours to my radio show on 610 of the
best radio stations in the country so
you clearly watch the show you're now
using my show to beg for money from your
adoring fans come on the program I'll
give you the full hour three hours in my
radio show I won't point out every
single lie every piece of propaganda
information that you have been peddling
for two straight years and guess what we
have every lie of yours Chronicle every
TV appearance Chronicle we will expose
your efforts to undercut this democracy
and undermine the President and say
things that are just false like
reportedly sending staff oh let's see
why did your staff meet with Michael
Kohn for ten hours before his recent
testimony well that doesn't sound that's
not witness tampering is it and that
sound a little bit like collusion and of
course that's nothing for shift because
he's the one guy we have on tape really
colluding with the Russians so that he
can impact the electoral process in this
country it's amazing this is on tape
well somebody please send this to robert
muller maybe missed it take a look and
she met with Trump and she brought him
one our Russian girl celebrity Olga boo
Sava who also known as a person with a
strange reputation Oh Olga blooms ever
what's the nature of the compromise well
there were pictures of naked Trump and
was made aware of the availability of
the compromising material yes of course
thank you very much we will be back in
touch with you through our staff to make
arrangements to obtain these materials
for our committee and and for the FBI
and I appreciate your reaching out to us
naked
Trump pictures and Vladimir knows about
it by the way was a hole he got set up
but he thought he was talking to a real
Russian just like kind of Obama didn't
know his mic was hot on telling me or
I'll have a lot more flexibility after
the election tell him we can do the deal
of them but we won't tell the American
people so you can see the hate Trump mob
they're willing to do anything
everything to try and take down this
president like making materially false
statements to a FISA Court we're now
getting all the confirmation I told you
it was coming tick-tock of what the
hell's John Solomon reported months ago
in the dirty steal dossier according to
newly released testimony Bruce or warned
the top FBI brass yes Christopher steel
hated the president that the dossier was
tainted with an anti-trump bias that it
was never verified it was never
corroborated now you got to get steal
some credit cuz he managed to get paid
by a Russian oligarch the FBI Hillary
Clinton's campaign and the DNC all for
the same dossier that he doesn't even
stand by himself
pretty amazing job of you can get it now
in the 2016 FISA application against
Carter pager reads quote the FBI is
unaware of any derogatory information
pertaining to Christopher Steele why it
gives us some of the most damning
evidence yet the top officials inside
upper echelon not rank and file the FBI
DOJ they made materially false
statements to the FISA Court they
purposely withheld information they
committed a conspiracy of fraud against
an American citizen denying that citizen
of their constitutional rights all to
get an opportunity to spy on the Trump
campaign through an associate at the
height of the 2016 election then they
leaked all the lies to you we the people
so that it would influence your vote
Russian paid for lies to influence the
vote let not your heart be troubled
tonight my sources are again confirming
to me that those who broke the law
those that abused power they are going
to be held accountable so far we've not
been wrong